la nouvelle vient de tomber par tous les
nains de jardin disparaissent ils ont
tous disparu je suis sherlock note je
vous aiderai à les retrouver c'est
mission impossible avec ses dangers
déguisement dans ce drone est drôle
d'énergumène cette année ils devront
résoudre un mystère
mystère la plus incroyable des avants kg
et charlotte qu'il nomme se faire dans
les français rôdé nos jobs à part pour
celui que vous venez de casser son
sherlock noces j'ai les mêmes jardin
c'est la fête pendant médiatique
commence à disparaître
juliette les autres ils ont tous disparu
il n'y en a qu'un petit peu mulet look
est je suis chez renault
je vous aiderai à les retrouver par le
réalisateur de kung fu panda
nous devons le fondre dans la foule
passé totalement innocent mannino nous
allons le 2-3 partez
j'ai près on est prêt et vous savez ce
qu'il faut faire
qu'est ce qu'on doit faire l'incroyable
aventure fait quelque chose
j'ai mal au coeur pour toute la famille
devant en avant stop
nous sommes repérés
à
sherlock qui nomme aucun écureuils ne se
trémousse de la sorte les amis c'est
plus une démonstration
[Musique]
au cinéma le 11 avril